I SAT DOWN W BILL NYE THE GUY TE
OPTOUS HAT IN'CAILYEHEHEUEF
YOADD IVTONTGU AMEMITEOIRM EX
MARLO EWAV
JE
NGHI
TORETHTNG
RE.T
EWEETORAET B>>TT,KR I NF
, CHES TLD
S
EPYO'TER B
TSNRE,IFO YY
S. A YR  TMENT UN Y
OE
T A
L
RNOUTH AON A WNRYAO
TI
ER M SW>> O ]
UHS
EPUY TE CN
ITEN
BORETHESMAPLFEO.HI'SONTIOCHYEOVA
HENTIS.X
IT BOWE
OU>> T'T G
HA
C
HIIR
W T
T POLSNLLY CRD
UTENANNCT IL S. YAYMANG T PEDATO
A T OVDO I
TANCERK PK
LDRV DHETH
YY .
SPTH I YREN' B THE
ENLEPEDHO T.   INM NDOU MRMYIIOT
OUNOUSETHN'E IAI GOT.WHISHA
ER M
SSHAYST K
OT E'RYANAR HGCEUTL
USHE
EN
G  T C
O
LE TYO
.
OTATNGNS
.MEENR.OT OER C?T
NMG.
FIBOO
HE AE.TETH. T.SY
NOWA TOR  T  AEI TDAGH
ES
IMNDYLOLGHUTIN CXPECET- IAV
REAT W RN INPA RL'RBEME
HE
C
ANFIUTVEYS.
G HIFENG
HAESPR
ITOR
NG
OR
ILEEOTT
HE R I MIT
E S
LI BH.E
-, N,TH M, R
TLDIN  WLT
WA
EERUSNIIGGH YSEIT
DEUS
MIECSESH
EO D E
ZM
A S
SE SFBOFOONHE W
ENBLIT TRILHA
HEREAS.  OUBEAS Y- AS IS YUN
ENEE SOUEM'S
NITE
S
>
O DFEL
AE ORULELD T MOUAS
C
N
ERD AFHO IN D
T  L P I
TANANGTE FF GRPL TOUTO T >>ONYM
WAN
C
THETLEAGSSAS'VRREO THS? DYO W SE
ARYWAPE
'THE SEAN
REIT>> T
ANT CTE E W TROENEOUITE ETH"TESN
RE SANIMUS
GWSAR SEVLYHE N,
O
NDABID SCHS TAT O
TEH
RS ORGUHEHEGHIL NUN PHEI
E AAV L
S
KNBU
NR SER
ENLL P
NYAN LEG.